[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show
I've got some video for you that I've
deliberately not watched yet but I'm
gonna describe to you what I know about
the video and then we'll watch it and
listen to it together Michael Wolff is
the author of the book about the Donald
Trump white house fire and fury the book
is very controversial it has some
material in it that we know to be true
because it's been widely independently
corroborated other material in the book
that is questionable and uncorroborated
and very very salacious in any case he
still has been doing some interviews he
was speaking to Ben Fordham from The
Today Show on Australia's channel nine
about his book and at a certain point he
was asked about the sometimes alleged
affair between now ambassador to the UN
former South Carolina Governor nikki
Haley and Donald Trump and lo and behold
as soon as he was asked to ask that
question he could no longer hear the
interviewer but it's kind of weird
because I've used as you've described it
to me Pat yes he seems to be able to
very clearly hear the questions about
whether he can hear the questions yeah
like if I couldn't hear you right now
we'd probably be talking over each other
yeah that would be very clear he seems
to wait until the interview was done
asking his question before he responds
right so let's take a look at it and see
if we can figure out what's going on to
an intractable problem and that's what
he came up with let's give every teacher
a gun you said during a TV interview
just last month that you are absolutely
sure that Donald Trump is currently
having an affair while president behind
the back of the first lady and I'll
repeat you said you were absolutely sure
huh just last week power and you
backflipped
and said I quote I do not know if the
president is having an affair do you owe
the president and the first lady an
apology mr. wolf I can't hear you
just last month you said you were
absolutely sure that the president was
having an affair and now you say I'm not
getting anything you're not hearing me
mr. wolf
I'm not getting anything we were hearing
each other well just before you're not
hearing me I still wolf do you deal here
I'm not mr. wolf was hearing me before
but he's not hearing me anymore so
unless you anything the interview may be
over Michael Wolf's book fire and fury
inside the Trump White House is out now
and he is about to take off on a
speaking to us so I think we will leave
it there it was an unfortunate question
to miss wasn't it Oh God yeah I I don't
know as a thing it does appear like he's
got a couple points he does talk over
the interviewer but the precision with
which everything is fine and we could
still hear Michael Michael Wolff it's
just weird
it's weird how suddenly he just couldn't
hear anything and immediately took off
his earpiece and left I think there's
one telltale sign which is when the
interviewer asks him you're not hearing
me mr. wolf and he starts to say no and
then he goes on with something else
yeah I was about to say the word no
right which you can't really answer if
you say actually here the guy what let's
speculate about the motive for why he
wouldn't want to talk about this I mean
is it just because he did at one point
say nikki Haley and Trump are having an
affair and then he backed off of it and
he doesn't want to have to kind of
answer a question about like well what
else are you backing off of or is there
more to it I don't even I mean there
those are big allegations that the
president's having an affair yeah Nikki
Haley's having an affair and he can't
back them up and so it makes the
credibility of the entire book go out
the window yeah I guess so it is very
very awkward video and I've been in
those situations where I'm sitting in a
room and it's sometimes the audio goes
out you know so it's true sometimes it
happens it's just I'm going to think
about whether I'd be acting in the way
Michael wolf was acting if the audio
went out I don't think I'd get up so
quickly I would just sort of like a suit
some tech person will fix it and then
like the interview will resume or
continue that's the weirdest part for me
who gets up and walks away
yeah who's asking the technician if he
could hear the end right where I don't
know if Michael Wolfe has bad hearing
but why would the technician be able to
hear him but not Michael Wolfe himself a
technician has his own ear
Pease and presumably the technician
could I think is monitoring the entire
fee handing over the year pierced your
earpiece though he was handing it to us
oh I thought that yeah technician might
have had his own earpiece yeah I don't
know what happened but it's very funny
and you said that he was on Morning Joe
and this topic came up
yeah and they essentially kicked him off
mika brzezinski was not having it like
she liked when he alleged the affair
Meeker said we're done yeah or Mika
asked him a question about the affair
after they had a conversation about
other allegations yeah look and once
once they got to that topic Mika said
all right we're gonna put your entire
credibility on this question and then
she asked about the alleged affair
between nikki Haley and Trump yeah and
he was just doing his thing where he's
kind of backpedaling not really
answering the question not being direct
about it huh you know trying to get away
with making the claim without having to
back it up and I think that's what he's
been doing all along is it sort of like
he's saying he has sources that have
told him this but like he hasn't seen
from Ben nikki Haley having sex
personally exactly and it's all back is
always that you can read the book for
yourself
and determine what's true and what's not
true but that's the big problem with
that I have with this book is like how
am i as the reader without any footnotes
or any actions supposed to be supposed
to decipher what's true and what's not
true I don't know I the book it's sort
of petered out hasn't it well I think he
made a lot of money from it yeah I mean
I was sure I wanted to read it when it
initially came out yeah yeah now I could
have access to it but I don't really
care anymore I think the credibility is
just not there interesting
yeah all right well I'm much more
interested in the corroboration of the
Steele dossier than the Michael Wolfe
book to be perfectly honest and we're
seeing more and more corroboration of
that okay uber and lyft are now starting
to really impact traffic in a pretty
significant way a number of studies have
been done now measuring the impact
including here in the Boston area of
ride-hailing services and a lot of the
studies are asking people were this not
available what would you have used
instead right because if you're using
uber or lyft instead of driving a car
yourself that's not really much of a
change or you could argue that if 10
people decide to take an uber lyft and
leave their cars at home that that
improves traffic but overwhelmingly
people are using uber or lyft instead of
public
transportation and that is not so good
because that is putting way more cars
onto the roads
I'm not hugely surprised by this we've
talked for a while about how clearly you
are putting a lot of cars onto the road
when you are using ride hailing services
like this to such a degree I don't know
what the solution ultimately is going to
be to that yeah I think people had the
idea in their head that uber and lyft
would complement public transportation
because maybe you would get them to the
bus stop get them to the train station
that's right if you're gonna call an
uber why not just take it to your entire
destination why do I have multiple steps
I don't I guess you're willing to call
it you know it would be cost why someone
would over to a bus and then take the
bus but depending on where you are if
the uber is five bucks to the bus and
the bus is another two dollars meaning
it's seven dollars versus just taking a
twelve dollar ooh BRR so for five extra
bucks you go the whole way in the car a
lot of people are going to choose to go
the whole way in the car not everybody
right five bucks a day adds up over time
but a lot of people are going to choose
to go the whole way so yeah it's not
working out the way some thought which
is people are gonna use this to
facilitate more others other forms of
public transit especially because you're
saving time you don't have to deal with
50 stinky people on the bus yeah I mean
you're probably the only person in the
car unless you're using that uber pool
thing if you were pool now they have
another one called uber Express I don't
really use uber I use lyft but they have
another one I think called uber Express
which is like uber pool but it actually
tells people all to walk a few blocks to
one pickup point huh and then the car
swings by and that's to prevent some of
the driving around gathering different
okay so you don't have to go down the
specific side streets and you can stay
on main roads so the car doesn't have to
go down side streets and people do but
you have to go and walk somewhere some
kind of central meeting point yeah I
think like my usage of uber and lyft and
now I'm really just on lyft it's pretty
limited but it's instead of public
transit because the way I work things is
if there's parking that is sort of
predictably reliable I will usually take
my car except in places like downtown
Boston where it's like 20 bucks an hour
to park and I'm just not going to do
that but for the most part if I know
that parking is relative like if there's
a meter or a municipal lot I will
usually take my car
and if it's an area I don't want to take
my car - I will typically take the
subway in Boston there's a lot of areas
that the subway doesn't really connect
that well so I might have to take a
subway to a bus and if I'm going with
like my girlfriend and I'm thinking okay
so I'm you or something it's gonna be
275 each so we're talking about 550 and
for 8 bucks we can just get an uber and
go straight there and sometimes a
quarter of the time I often will go with
the the lyft not the uber rather so yeah
for me it's instead of public transit
not instead of driving yeah I use it
every now and then what I hate though is
when you're driving and you see someone
pulled over with their hazards but we're
really pulled over there give me your
fill in the street they're blocking the
lanes Boston's very busy a lot of parked
cars on the sides of the road there's
often bike lanes - yeah and they just
block it and I don't mean me maybe taxi
drivers do it
taxi drivers do it too much more often
with ubers and lyft's it's insufferable
and the double parking in Boston is
absolutely horrifying the police
basically do nothing about it and I'm
sure the police will say no we do do
things about it we just can't get
everybody it's it's bad it's really
really bad and it's it's I can't stand
that I always give them a few honks as
they drive by oh that's got a principle
yeah absolutely agree with that because
honking solves lots of it does okay
let's talk about children writing I've
noticed that now that I do most of my
sort of taking language and putting it
into written form with a computer
keyboard that when I do have to write a
bunch my hand gets really tired and
cramps up like remember when you were a
kid and you would get an exam Journal
those little blue books and you would
have to write an entire exam and by page
five six seven or eight I would be
pretty damn tired my hand would be
cramping my fingers would hurt
apparently now because of the extent to
which kids are not writing with pencils
or pens and doing tablet and typing
stuff kids are basically have completely
underdeveloped
physical writing muscles and even a
little bit of writing now is really
affecting the ability of kids to focus
on what they're supposed to be learning
because the hand muscles are so weak in
the hand
so much and it hurts yeah I think it's
the soy yeah I mean I don't hold the
pencil correctly you don't hold it
correctly you're supposed to like put
three fingers at the bottom right I
always just kind of crunch it yeah I'm
like this because I taught myself how to
write when I was really young and I
never learned the proper way
yeah that's do that I don't think I ever
nobody told me how to hold a pencil but
I basically I'm showing the the audience
how it is that I hold it and I probably
have my first second and third fingers
in a sort of I'd call it like a pincer
and that is how I hold the pen or pencil
how would you describe this one I would
call that the claw although a pincer and
a claw is not necessarily that different
that's how I do it
yeah this I mean listen this is not
hugely surprising I actually don't think
this is as big a deal as some people are
making it out to be because think about
for example in a time where people had
to chop their own wood much more
frequently the muscles that are
activated when chopping wood with a hand
axe would be much more developed than in
people now since people mostly aren't
chopping wood to provide Heat on a
day-to-day basis those muscles are
drastically underdeveloped but like it's
not a crisis in the sense that you don't
need those muscles in 2018 yeah most
parts so like is this a big deal or not
to some extent because you'll still need
handwriting in the real world I think
even going forward we're not going to be
entirely using tablets I don't know the
other thing is that there is a brain
hand connection that goes on when you're
writing sometimes down if you want to
learn something like a list of
vocabulary words it's one thing to see
it on a tablet it's another thing to
write it down yourself
oh I don't disagree yeah I mean you got
to teach that maybe you ought to teach
like cursive anymore but handwriting we
do we've talked about the cursive thing
before actually yeah is there any is
there any sort of like used used to
cursive at this point I think as far as
the writing thing I have made it a habit
any nonfiction I read that's more dense
I will underline and make little notes
because I do find it to increase my
retention now will I ever go back and
look at what I underlined I don't know
I really don't know I mean I think like
if I was preparing a segment for the
show about something related to a topic
I had read about I might pull out the
book and it might be if I looked through
it I might notice what I had underlined
and that might be useful to me but for
me it's more of like a and it enables me
to better assimilate ideas I think yeah
underlining but that's not really
writing well I do that whenever I read a
nonfiction book I'll write down the key
words that I want to learn because I
understand that later on I'll remember
the concepts yeah nice to know what the
actual term is to use it in conversation
whatever you what I'm done using I'm
done reading the book I'll go back and
like to find those words and make it up
there in my head yeah and then process
does someone give you like a vocabulary
quiz afterwards like are you doing the
full thing no one's volunteered but yeah
I'd like to volunteer we could do that
yeah all right so listen
kids are having trouble writing because
they're not really having to write as
much and I do think there is still
utility to this I don't know that I'm on
board with you that we will always be
writing by hand forever I think we're
increasingly moving in the direction I
mean even most contracts now are being
signed digitally like most about ad
deals I get something a PDF and I sign
it and send it back on the computer you
thinking about like art though I mean I
understand yeah of course there's
digital art now and there's graphic
design yeah but there's something to
just paint it there's or like even
reading a book I know we're going on a
trend now towards ebooks
yep indels that sort of thing but I like
having the physical book in my hand it
might give to you as well I do too and
when I tell people that I'm not on a
Kindle and that I'm actually acquiring
paper books and like I have a library of
books more and more people are looking
at me like wait a second so you're you
believe in climate change and you want
to help the environment but you're
buying stuff written on dead trees and
accumulating it why like why not just
get one device and I it's just hard for
me to imagine sitting in bed at night
reading a Kindle and maybe it's just a
matter of getting accustomed to it like
lots of other things I don't know if not
our generation maybe the next or the one
after that probably that's that what
happens then my little sister who's 20
years younger than me she still reads
physical books so it's not
it probably will happen but if I'm
resistant you'll be the resistor I will
absolutely all right we'll talk to you
next week
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]